when you're when you hit those things
those areas of discomfort you're going
to have the urge to bolt to leave
and we're just asking you like if you're
really here to you know get your money's
worth and stick through those those
moments
and know that there is something for you
to look at if you if you hit one of
those things for example sashes we wear
these sashes around our neck
that was super cheesy didn't like it um
and then that would mean you have an
issue with like measurement or like
there's a ranking system so you have an
issue with authority
which may or may not be true you know
um or calling keith vanguard why do you
have a problem with that like which if
you were
in the court system would you call your
honor
bob because you don't want to use the
term you know
right right right right like every
single thing that was weird
had a an answer and if you had a problem
with it it pointed to a thing within
yourself so i kind of learned to go like
okay i'm uncomfortable which means i've
got something
now this is like i trusted mark and i
trusted the system
a lot of not a lot of people but maybe
one in 30 would come take our training
and they'd be like
no especially if they'd grown up and say
another high control group like
jehovah's witness
or you know an extremely religious
background or whatever they'd be like
i've never done that
you said one in 30 would say no but
you're saying that the percentage of
people that would come
in and go to these seminars once they
were there most of them were in
most of them were in but i'd say almost
every training we did there'd maybe be
one person on day one that had such an
extreme reaction
to either the sashes or the vanguard or
something that they were like i'm out
and then they were out and we and keith
actually
said that all of those things were what
he called the guardian at the gates
so somebody had such a reaction to that
and meant we didn't want them in there
because they were suppressive
it's oppressive ah yes so like
you learn to like i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna voice anything but being
uncomfortable with this because it's
just gonna expose that like
maybe i'm suppressive right right
so that base assumption that if i'm
uncomfortable
i'm gonna override that is one of the
most dangerous things that they did and
i think keith
knew that to systematically dismantle
intuition
so your gut he was getting rid of your
gut so to speak
yeah and saying because here's the thing
your gut there is truth in the fact that
i could have a feeling that might not be
right like i could meet you and maybe
like
your eyebrows reminded me of somebody
that hurt me like 10 years ago and it
triggers me and that's not based on any
kind of reality
right so that happens
but there's also truth to say if my body
is saying f
out i should listen to that right so he
screwed with that ability to
to have a moral compass and you think
that was his agenda all along
yes to sort of get rid of your gut
response and make
you go past that so you stay with it
yes to not trust yourself your own
intuition
yes that's to make somebody else the
author wow that's that's
for lack of a better word that's that's
[ __ ] right but you know maybe at that
time it's like
you're seeking all these things this
these con this confidence
what was it that in that five-day
seminar was there a moment where you're
like
i feel like i should do this this is
gonna help yeah what was that moment
there was a couple and mark was right by
day three i was sold
um i had a number of big shifts and
i do think as you know even though i
believe keith is a sociopath and a
narcissist and all those things
is brilliant and he repackaged a whole
bunch of
therapeutic models into one five-day
so some cognitive behavioral therapy
neuro-linguistic programming
um basic buddhist beliefs about
happiness and where happiness comes from
which is i'm sure you've heard by now
it's an inside job
you know nothing from the outside world
money happy no no yeah car
no yeah so he
cobbled these things together and you
know if you you've done
anyone's done therapy you know you
usually go like once a week if that
right that's an hour a week imagine
doing 15 hours
12 to 15 hours five days in a row
you're just like working through stuff
working through stuff working through
stuff and
having these huge awarenesses about like
you know my relationship to money my
relationship
to acting my my relationship to like
what my values are
and this exercise where like you write
down all your values and what's most
important to you so you can make
i had a really hard time making
decisions before esp i'd be like
i should do this i should do that should
i do this job or that chat should i wear
this or this like i just
i was a nightmare to those around me so
now i had this like decision making
tool which really helped me and esp was
it's
it's the name before nexium right yeah
that's so that's executive success
programs
right that's what you went to an
executive success program which
ultimately is nexium which became next
scene yeah nexium wasn't even a word
that was on my radar until much later
was the parent company and esp executive
success program was like a subset of
that right that's what the training was
that i did
yeah i just want to let people know that
and yeah
not esp exactly
exactly
you